unvaccinated adults hospitalized with
covet 19 cost the american health system
at least 2.3 billion dollars in june and
july this year according to research by
the kaiser family foundation
most of that cost will be borne by
society as a whole and not by
unvaccinated patients as many will only
pay a fraction of what care costs
according to the research more than one
hundred thousand covet 19
hospitalizations could have been
prevented by vaccination in june and
july kaiser found that the average cost
of covet 19 hospitalization is around 20
giving them the 2.3 billion dollar price
tag the report concludes that those
refusing covet 19 vaccines inflict a
greater burden on taxpayers and risk
higher insurance premiums for businesses
and workers some businesses are
considering raising premiums to
encourage their workers to get
vaccinated and the unvaccinated will
face higher out-of-pocket costs for
hospitalization by august 2021 72
percent of the largest health plans
stopped cost sharing for covid19
treatment according to kaiser kaiser
also notes their figure is likely a
conservative estimate pointing to an
increase in covet 19 cases
hospitalizations and deaths in august
and estimates likely underestimating the
burden of preventable hospital
admissions
[Music]
you